so let me ask you is this the end for
donald trump
it's not the end um but it forecloses
you know one hopeful path i think
you know i think there are basically two
viable possible we can i mean we're
gonna get let's do it
okay texas from cnbc texas sues four
battleground states and supreme court
over unlawful election results in 2020
presidential race
texas republican attorney general ken
paxton on tuesday
filed a lawsuit in the u.s supreme court
to invalidate presidential election
results in pennsylvania georgia
wisconsin michigan
the lawsuit asserts that unlawful
election results in those four states
which president-elect joe biden won
should be declared unconstitutional the
filing argues
that those states use the coronavirus
pandemic as an excuse to unlawfully
change their election rules
experts in election law were quick to
dismiss the likelihood of the nine
supreme court justice taking the case
now i'm just gonna i'm gonna poke your
buttons a little bit and say joe biden
is not the president-elect but uh that's
fine
but he's not he's not right yeah no like
technically not i mean no literally not
but technically is
in order to be literally the so to be
just like a bugaboo of yours
no no no well no because you tweeted
that joe biden was present elect right
no i
treated the joe biden one okay well you
said it earlier so i'm just making the
point to clarify for everybody what it
means
president-elect is january 6 when all
the votes are counted and they say
he will now be inaugurated you know in
you know 14 days or whatever
in two weeks that's when he is
president-elect officially because we go
by the electoral college
technically he is because the you know
everybody recognizes the projections
from all the states and thus it's going
to happen anyway
so it's an m they call they consider it
an uh an inevitability
right okay so let's talk about texas
okay let's talk about texas all right
um uh is this trump uh he's guaranteed
to win now it's over trump
no no i mean so i mean this is a very
interesting thing like i had to learn i
read about it today because i was like
well i i mean this is something you
remember from your con law classes like
a footnote
that by the way when states to each
other they go to the straight to the
supreme court but it's not something
that
comes up very often i think i looked
into it there's been an average of one
case like this every year
um probably here for like the last
hundred years and out of all the cases
that the supreme court takes
so like other states routinely sue other
states the point is it's not routine
like one cases
one case like this every year happens
out of like 75 or 100 or 150 that the
supreme court takes so it's not
it happens and it's usually designed for
things like water rights you know
um like so but like so like wisconsin
and illinois or something yeah right i
mean they have the they have the great
lakes coalition though so they're all
pretty much in agreement but it would be
like i i remember there was arizona
suing
uh the great lakes saying we deserve
access to the water because it's on
american soil or whatever and that was
like the actually the original idea
behind the supreme court was you had to
have a place where the states could
resolve their disputes
um that's so what's what's this lawsuit
about what are they saying so they're
suing and they're basically saying
pennsylvania michigan
wisconsin et cetera all didn't follow
their own law election laws all
made a mockery of election integrity as
a result that injures us
the state of texas not just because we
don't our electors don't get to vote for
president and it's canceled out by these
illegitimate unconstitutional votes
but also even more important from the
state perspective
in terms of its own interests the vice
presidency is now is now changed and
you know we're a state we have a direct
interest in our senate representation
and our ability to
vote there and the vice president is the
president of the senate who breaks ties
so basically so they're saying like look
we have standing to object here
um there are all these problems and you
know you should take this and
actually we think you the supreme court
don't have any discretion we think you
have to take this case
um and then you know going through the
litany of problems that we've been
talking about they said scotus has to
take it
they argued that um that's not doesn't
look like it's a majority view on the
supreme court it looks like it's just a
leto and thomas although we don't know
how the
three latest justices would rule on it
um
that said i i am doubtful but not like
you know i don't think it's
a guarantee or anything but i'm doubtful
that the supreme court will take this
case and it kind of gets to the heart of
you know what does the supreme court
normally do it does appeals
right right again it sits as a court of
review when the case comes to it in the
first instance the supreme court's like
well i guess we have to have like a
trial or something right like we need to
have evidence we need to have witnesses
and how they actually do that is they
literally just appoint a basically a
special master which is like a private
judge
and they're like oh i guess we have one
of those cases we have to take well here
you go private judge go resolve
it and we'll deal with this and then
after everything's presented they can
rule on what
right but because they're not equipped
for it they've kind of found ways to say
like okay how do we like not take these
cases if we don't have to
right like we're an appeals court we
don't like to decide things in the first
instance
how do we let's let's narrow this down
as much as possible and so the way they
do it now is
they say well can the underlying
interests of this case be vindicated in
another lawsuit somewhere else okay and
if they can't then fine we'll take
it but if they can with other litigants
in a forum so that things go normally
and percolate their way up
then we'll do that this is one of those
cases where there are other forums where
the underlying interest being talked
about
in the lawsuit can be can be vindicated
there are election contest laws in all
these states
which is actually one of the avenues we
haven't really talked about where i
think there's a real chance of
doing something and persuading a judge
so what is that uh well so for example
in georgia
president trump and david shaffer the
director of georgia republicans filed a
formal election contests in georgia
state court
under georgia's election contest law
what was that that was like two days ago
is that still going yeah that's still
going they just filed it um i think on
the fifth
doesn't that doesn't that plan to safe
harbor somehow like they've got to
resolve that i don't know
i don't know how you know how it
interplays with state harbor but i just
know that like
it's the first lawsuit i saw where i was
like oh there isn't an obvious
procedural problem with this
right that's going to prevent this from
getting heard right and that's not
that's going to lead to a judge just
kicking it out of court because that's
been the problem with all the lawsuits
so far like the other side gets up and
says
oh you have no standing and mootness and
like go down the list of like
problems with your lawsuit that you mean
we don't even get to the side or some of
them are just
i don't know the the kraken lawsuits i
mean the kraken lawsuits got dismissed
yesterday i mean one of them got
dismissed from the bench which you never
see
like that's how bad it was or what yeah
i mean because normally i mean a
district judge is worried about being
reversed on appeal it's humiliating
you're uh it's your superiors seems to
happen all the time though right it does
but they want to avoid it because it's
humiliating right like they don't like
being reversed it says they got the law
wrong and they didn't do their job
properly
and it's a public opinion like imagine
getting a performance review and having
it be
like and then imagine being the supreme
court and you're just chilling because
no one's gonna
um but so they don't so as a result if
they don't want to be reversed they try
and put all their decisions in writing
and make them pretty rigorous so that
they survive appeal
literally the guy just looked at the
kraken plaintiffs and their lawyers and
was like you guys lose for like four
reasons one two three four
you never could get into court even if
you could your claims are meritless go
away
like it was just it was i haven't seen
that in a serious piece of litigation in
a long time
i mean was it wasn't the filing missing
spacings between words oh they're typos
all over the place but
not typos like there were there were
whole paragraphs that had no spaces
it was a mess it was not proofread and
what is this
i mean it's it's it's like they're i
don't know what's going on
i don't understand it because if i when
i was practicing law if i did that i
would have gotten fired
so the reason the reason i ask is a lot
of i hear a lot it's 4d chess
they're trying to lose on purpose to get
to supreme court there's nothing good
about losing right you're going to go to
the supreme court even if you
win because the other like again like
say sydney powell wins her law her
lawsuit at the district court level you
think the other side would be like
well we're we're whoa well we're done
here i guess we're just leaving
you know yeah they'd appeal and say
maybe it would make it it's going there
no matter what right and you'd like to
have like
an opinion that says you were right from
the lower court at least to like give
you some presumption like
this is a strategy to losing when they
lost uh when trump's campaign lost and i
think the third circuit over yeah i was
basically saying
you know a bunch of people were like
that's exactly what we wanted thanks for
ruling so quickly so we can get to
scotus
and i'm like there is a good point we
made in that
if they're gonna win and they're still
going to scotus anyway then they want to
get there as fast as possible
right so that makes sense sort of but
still
you'd rather win than lose even if that
was the case and you don't want to lose
the way they lost in the third circuit
which was again in all these procedural
problems like things like
even if you won your point you wouldn't
have enough to change the result of the
election based on the claims you're
making so you can't you have to get out
of court or
you know well that was that was they
wanted to amend the complaint a second
time or whatever
oh yeah gosh the the way they went about
that was so silly they wanted to amend
the complaint a second time they weren't
actually appealing the underlying
substantive ruling
they were appealing the decision by the
district court not to let them fix their
complaint
um and that's usually that's granted
liberally because you wanna
basically right everybody should have
access to justice so they shouldn't be
kicked out according to technicality
but the trump campaign had been there
saying we have to get this done by
november 23rd we need to do it really
fast because
you know the election certification ball
we have to get it done fast
and then the district court just misses
their case and they're like oh well can
we fix the complaint and take another
six weeks
and this record's like no wow
it's too late yeah so so my question
then is and
we'll go back to taxes and get to the
heart of the the
that that lawsuit rudy giuliani
is he a old crackpot well past his prime
who's falling apart or
a mad freaky genius playing 4d chest
who's going to pull out a tremendous
victory
it's only one or the other there's no
middle ground well i mean i i don't want
to be mean to
giuliana but he's the most and he's
doing like what many other people are
doing it's pr
in the place of law like i was really
disappointed to see giuliani being
selected to argue the appeal
giuliani is not an appellate lawyer he
hasn't practiced appellate law in years
he hasn't argued any appeals
um as far as i know i mean it's possible
i'm wrong about this and he already
appealed recently but
that's a that's like a practice like you
and and he was they were doing things
like
they one of the things that in the third
circuit case people didn't miss this too
they appealed a temporary restraining
order that's actually wrong you can't do
that
you have to apply to the appellate court
for an injunction pending appeal
how do you know this they don't and
you're not even this kind of i didn't
know this beforehand but i
i read about it afterwards shouldn't
they have read it before
yeah exactly this is why you would hire
experienced appellate lawyers because
they don't they don't have to wait for
the judge's opinion to find out what
they should have done
so so but but you're a big trump
supporter yeah you're you're
i mean you were mentioning this before
the show that we had a conversation a
couple years ago
where i was like it sounds like we agree
on all of these like you know culture
war kind of issues and stuff
and then i i don't know if you was you
asked me or i asked you or something
like you asked me then why wasn't i
supporting trump or something
yeah and then like i had some answers
back in the day i mean back then it was
like those are the bolton stuff and
and the foreign policy failures and
stuff and that that's kind of what
but the riots really changed things too
so i'm like you know what man everything
else i kind of the window
but um so so what you're saying is the
best chance that trump has right now
to to legitimately win as per some kind
of
constitutional processes martial law
send in the troops go in just lock
everybody up arrest them all is that
really winning i don't know
i don't i don't want any coups i think i
think there's some possibility of the
texas law getting taken
the lawsuit getting taken and it's one
virtue if you will is that
it only has to get past this one big
procedural hurdle and then they can hear
the case
and what's that that's the supreme court
deciding to grant permission for them to
file the complaint
so they haven't even filed a complaint
yet yeah they've asked for permission to
file it this and people
people are getting this run they like
see it on the dock and they're like oh
scotus has agreed to hear it
no scotus has when they do that they're
saying oh you you
met the proper steps to ask for
permission to file this complaint that's
all we're saying you you
your filing was procedurally correct so
far and then they decide if they want to
hear it or not yeah they decided they
want to hear it or not
odds are the my answer is they probably
won't but if they get past that
if this the goddess decides on this one
little decision they're going to
overlook some how they've been doing
things in the past and is it majority
rule
yeah it's a five-four decision okay five
four because you know count roberts
no roberts is
um but like that's but even so i think
you know if i'm betting man i'm not
betting on the success of that
litigation because
in general i mean it's the problem we
talked about earlier that
the interests underlying that they're
trying to be vindicated there right
election irregularities there's
processes in the individual states to
deal with it
and the supreme court generally hates
having these original jurisdiction cases
and only will take them
if there's no other place that can be
vindicated i don't know election betting
odds has trump
up 0.7 percent today considering the
news
you'd think you'd be going down but they
still have around 10 to win
and be the next president that's free
money
that's that's free money that's what
that is i don't know i would i still
wouldn't make that would
i i i'm gonna disclose something maybe i
shouldn't i after i
like all this nonsense with the one
stuff i looked on predicted and they
were
predict it was giving me like they said
trump was at 13 percent to win
and you can make a bet on based on that
well but uh
so predict it has trump at 14. oh wow
that's like wait that's way too high
yeah but you know you know what it is
though like it's because you can buy
them
and then sell them when they go up so
when it's at 10 cents people are like
i'll buy it because
some news will come out it'll go to 12
and then i'll sell out yeah you know and
then make two cents
right i keep telling everybody man
there's there's two big plays right here
if you really think trump's got you know
40 chests
and the kraken was only you know was was
actually hiding and wasn't slain at all
you really think trump's going to win
you bet you you got to go and you got to
place those bets right yeah that's right
i am not advocating the other way
right like if you really if you believe
that 100 trump's going to be in office
in two months that's that's absurd free
money you can make huge amounts of money
they'll be rich
i i saw one person social media where
someone claimed to have put like 20k
into betting on trump to win another
panicking because it was like their life
savings
but at the same time i'll tell you this
right here you think that's true it's
free money
uh yeah i mean then why don't you bet on
biden right now you can do it you did
pretty good you bet on biden yeah i got
like four grand writing
wow i i'm sure there's a ton of people
watching right now who are like oh i
hope he loses that money well here
here's i actually i have a there's sort
of an ethical thing like i think if you
make predictions like this you should
bet on them
betting is a tax on bs yeah right like
oh that's a good point yeah you know
uh so you know make a video like series
like you know when luke comes out and he
says something i'm like okay put the
money down you know what i mean right
like i mean it's
it's a real test like all the people who
are saying that trump's 100 gonna be in
office why aren't they
i mean there's huge amounts of money to
be made on the spot i mean you're gonna
make what is that 86 cents on the dollar
no i'm not going to make that much
because i'm betting on biden so like no
i'm saying like someone would have bet
so yeah you put down 14 cents for trump
you want a buck yeah so put down
14 bucks and 100. and and i mean the
point being like not that i don't want
trump to win i still do because i think
it would be good for the country but
it's like
i've made public predictions that trump
will not win and i feel like there's
sort of an ethical obligation to be
willing to put money on the public
predictions i make well i'll tell you
this in 2018 i was like i think the
republicans are going to are going to
keep control and they're going to
they're going to take they're going to
keep the house maybe even gain in the
house because all the culture war stuff
was getting crazy
and turns out i was wrong actually i was
right uh i was right for the first two
days
and then about a week later with all the
mail and mail and ballots that started
finding all over the place
then the democrats ended up winning so
uh it's interesting how that happened
right
yeah so uh so i was wrong then i said i
thought trump was gonna win this one
i did say i was i'm very tepid most of
the time but i was saying for months
leading up to the election like i think
trump is going to win
that's my gut feeling but you know biden
could win don't underestimate your
opponent
so when it turns out that you know now
the election is going biden's way
and i'm saying yeah biden's got this i'm
probably wrong again
and now we're all going like no i've
been saying over and over again
ever since the seventh it's it's 99.99
you know for biden the reason i reserve
that actually earlier on i said was like
97
yeah this was before trump actually
filed the lawsuits and i was like so he
has
all of these ways to challenge these
things and then as he's you know his
campaign and his and other republicans
and pro-trump individuals have been
losing i'm like
he of course still can right but is it
at a point where it's like winning the
lottery three times in a row or i mean
it's it's just really unlikely he has to
win all these election contests the time
you know we're running into the time
constraints where the electoral college
is going to vote i mean i you know even
at the beginning i said that the odds
have been prevailing after the election
results came in
like five percent at max well on january
6
the members of congress can contest can
can dispute right i mean and it happens
apparently
relatively often never works and never
goes into yeah i mean that's that's
like what i would expect to happen here
but isn't isn't it true
that uh what is it article two section
one or is it section two article one of
the concepts it sounds
if it's about congress it would be
article one constitution oh no they're
right
it's about the presidential elections
those articles that it doesn't matter
what the states say the state
legislatures always decide
yeah i mean i think there's the absolute
authorities placed in the state
legislatures but i don't think they're
going to do anything
to contradict the electoral college i
mean the president there is is crazy
like if you think about it the idea that
the
state elections don't matter and that
they don't i mean i mean
in like these are the craziest things
i've i've been reading more and more
about early
us history and the founding fathers
didn't want direct democracy like we
we all know that and we've actually been
sort of eroded
in that direction for some time yeah
like the 17th amendment which
i'm sure you're familiar with the senate
meaning making the senate elections
direct elections
exactly it used to be appointments by
the state legislatures right
and so senators were i i think that
system made more sense in a lot of ways
you know why
why we don't care about local elections
anymore and now our own communities fall
apart and become detached and and
dejected
yeah it's like our whole politics has
been nationalized like you can't run a
local paper doing local politics section
that's that's a whole you know no one
cares
no and what's really irksome to me is
when i see
someone running for congress talking
about how if they get elected they're
going to do all the good things for our
district
i'm like you represent the district to
the to the to the federal government
you don't clean up your district you go
to congress and vote on national level
policy
yeah and here's a real interesting thing
that that the whole idea of representing
your district that basically went out
the window with
the ban of earmarks you know that was
the way they represented their district
they got a little money
for like little pet projects they don't
even do that but the issue is
if you want your town cleaned up you got
to vote local
yeah and so before the 17th amendment
for those unfamiliar 17th amendment says
senators will be chosen by popular vote
before that the state legislatures would
essentially vote the problem was there
was bribery or
some kind of you know just crony bs yeah
that came out of like teddy roosevelt
and all the good government stuff that
they were doing yeah
and they're really interesting but think
about it if that's how the system still
worked
then you'd be like you gotta vote for
you know
who's the who's the pa state senator guy
who's um masteriano is that his name
yeah yeah you'd be like you got to make
sure he gets reelected because he's
going to make sure to get a good senator
for us
now it's like i don't even know who that
guy is and i live in pennsylvania right
not me personally i'm just saying
figuratively like you've got people who
live in pa
who can't even name who's in their
general assembly
don't i i i can you name well i mean i
just moved to maryland so i
but i don't know i don't even know who
my i lived in new york for five years i
can't name a single person
yeah i can name ocasio-cortez i didn't
live in her district yeah and she's
federal level i can't speak
i don't know who the councilmen are i
don't know who the the i don't know any
of that stuff
yeah it has been everything's being
nationalized and it's extremely
dangerous
it's not just about politics about media
yes let's say let's say
uh this was talked about like a decade
ago as local media was dying off because
the internet was replacing everything
this like it maybe this plays into the
culture in a lot of ways it used to be
that your tribe was was partially local
what you cared about locally might be
your high school football team versus
the neighboring town or whatever
but with social media the tribes became
singular national top level and
like very specific right if they were
they used to write about with uh with
this phenomenon
you could have a local politician be
extremely corrupt and there's no one to
write about it because no one cares
do i care about you know i don't know
the mayor of gainesville committing some
you know crime or whatever
no i care about desantis i don't care
about the smaller
town mayor or whatever or the city
councilman it's not going to make the
news no one's really going to care
unless it's really crazy like you know
he built a flying machine and starts
dropping mortars on people or something
i don't know maybe
i have to think about it though because
part of this is youth and you know
living wherever you want i wonder if
like we would change our minds if we
were you know
well i guess you are a homeowner but
yeah like if i was like personally a
homeowner in a place and knew i was
going to stay there for 20 years i might
start caring a little more about local
elections
yeah but but i mean your general point
though is correct about how
i mean our politics have been
nationalized our media has been
nationalized and the concerns people
have are
are you know ultimate you know and also
like i have a random thing like people
people would say to me like there's you
know i think you might have said this
there's no way joe biden got
80 million some votes like i think there
was a way
for sure right and people people uh were
i'll i'll just
let's play the media game normies were
radicalized
by a psychotic trump derangement media
apparatus that sought
to make money off of outrage about trump
and it created a whirlpool that sucked
in regular people
who snapped and said i just can't take
it anymore
biden boom yeah no i think that's
exactly that was exactly my thesis right
like
well but went away like what were people
even focused on over the last year but i
think trump's trump got oceans 11.
that's the way i put it
like the real heist happened months ago
when they were going around knocking on
doors and saying vote when they're doing
ballot harvesting
when they were doing those illegal uh
democracy in the park things of
wisconsin
there's the the viral videos of the
native american women saying like we're
gonna give you money if you vote like
make sure you tell us your vote
one tribe actually said send us a
picture of you voting we'll send you 20
bucks
like super illegal stuff oh yeah there i
i have no doubt there were tons of
shenanigans too like i remember you know
i was in philly on election day taking
you know
you were posting those videos yeah the
video the poll watcher uh i referenced
that when we had destiny here he's a
leftist and he said
if these claims of of like irregularity
and and and front and stuff were
or the observers being blocked were true
then where were all the videos on
election night and i was like well
chamberlain was there and he posted
like a video in the morning of like an
observer being kicked out yeah it
happened
yeah that's weird like there were so
many people who just a random side note
so many people denied that like i got i
saw fact checks that were like
yeah there was there was a reason
buzzfeed tried to fact check i literally
corrected her and she withdrew it to her
credit
yeah like you know so she was like he
wasn't you know and then
they tried claiming that knows he was at
the wrong precinct or whatever right
it's like and then you posted the photo
where it's like good in any precinct
right exactly so weird they they just
they were so
tuned for like oh there's misinformation
people are going to spread
misinformation i'm like
you guys know there's actual shenanigans
going on in philly and i don't know that
there was some like massive plot to like
poll watching it's more like that you
know what what i would attribute this
particular thing to was just sort of an
arrogance among the
the po the poll workers in that area
that like they were kings of the castle
they dictated what happened they didn't
need to pay but they
they did you see the video where the guy
yells all republican poll watchers
leave now or whatever i didn't see that
one but yeah yeah yeah there's there's
stuff like that there
or they're putting up boards to block
the windows do you see what scott adams
said about this
what he said if you are having a
discussion
about the potential irregularities or
fraud
after they barred observers and blocked
windows
you're a victim of misinformation uh and
essentially misdirection
yeah because as soon as they said no
witnesses
there's you can't do anything after that
right so when they when they say where's
the evidence of fraud i don't know they
kicked out the observers and boarded the
windows up right and i'm actually for
like a as a general rule like the idea
that if you if you wrongfully kick out
poll watchers then the votes go away
right
like we we assume we assume you've
committed fraud the presumption has you
committed fraud and you need to
affirmatively prove you didn't
right yes like i mean that's you know
like that's how it kind of works in the
court system generally like if you fail
to produce something of litigation
judges will issue it
eventually issue an adverse inference
instruction saying jury you need to
assume that this was terrible evidence
for them that proved that they did
something horrible
interesting um you know and that's the
way i should look at i think we should
look at
but we need to change the law to do this
right but i think we should change the
law about poll watchers
and and get people to a point where when
they are instructed about working a poll
and letting a poll watcher in there like
we better not
restrict this poll watcher because the
consequences of doing so are terrible
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you